では よろしくお願いします
ウデカンヒナヤンティ ネッティカ ウスカーラ ナマヤンティ テージェナン ダールン ナマヤンティ タッチェカ アッターナン ダマヤンティ パンディタ
それは日本訳どうなってますかね
灌漑人は水を導き 矢作り人は矢をためる
木工人は機材をため 賢者は自己を調整する
まあそれだけの意味ですけど
それはダンマパダにもありますしね
一応大体何も説む説明っていうのはね
ややこしい説明っていうのは全く要らないと思いますけどね
こちらではね 何を言いたがってるんでしょうかといえば
まあその人によってね
解釈は変わる可能性はあるんですけど
あの日本語でありのままという言葉がございますけどね
ありのままでよろしいと
まあこちらではちょっとありのままでいいということは言ってるわけでもないんですけどね
で 水をわざと管理しておくと
して それでまあ田んぼやら畑やらね
まあ役に立つようにすると
管理しなかったら水っていうのはなかなか使うものにはなりません
で 水そのものがね 水の勝手に流れしてしまうと
まあ何も役には立ちませんし
まあ栄養も全部取って海に行くだけですからね
まあそこでいろいろダム作ったり
いろんなことをしたりしてね
水を管理する まあ管理すると役に立つようになると
ですから この まあ心もそういうふうに
このありのままに放っておくんではなくて
ちゃんと戒めてみなさいということで
そうすると役に立つだろうと
ウスカーラ ナマヤンティ テージェナン
この矢なんか作る場合はね
すごい厳密に作らないと
なかなか使いものにはなりません
だからきちんとまっすぐにしなくちゃいけないし
まあ重さもそれなりに前と下の重さもそれぞれ計算しなくちゃいけないし
で 例えばやけに矢の後ろの方が重くなっちゃうと飛ぶわけでもないし
で 矢の先の方があまり重くなっちゃうと
それでも飛ぶわけじゃないし
まあですからまあちゃんと狙った的に当たるように
まっすぐに矢が飛べるようにどうすればいいかって
それは大変なこの技術が必要なんですね
ですから この昔の人々は普通の木の枝とかね
何か取ってきて まあそれはあらゆる工程を経てしっかりした矢を作るんですね
ですから その技術 まあ今はないんですけど
今の機械で作るんです
今はもう矢は本当は全然使ってないんだから
今のアーチェリーだったら当たればいいっていうぐらいのことですから
昔はそれ武器でしたからね
当たればいいっていうわけでもないしね
ですから すごい厳密に精密に使わなくちゃいけない
それで普通の木の枝とかね
持って それはどのようにちゃんとした矢に作るかっていうこと
大変な仕事なんですね
ですから 枝のままで先っぽに何か付けただけで矢にはなりません
ですから 管理する必要はあるということで
ダールン ナマヤンティ タッチェカ
木材を作る人々はあらゆる家具を作ったりするし
ですから この切り株いろいろ持って来ただけで家具にはなるわけではないし
タンスにもなりませんし
ベッドにもなりませんし
ですから そういうのはあらゆる工程を経て
大必要な家具にするんですね
ですから そういうことで役に立つようになるんだと
そのようにアッターナン ダマヤンティ パンディタ
賢者は自分の自己を調整して戒めてみるんだと
こちらで言ってるのは
この生まれたまんまで
もうありのままの生き方っていうのは良くないっていうことなんですね
ありのままに見るということは
この世間でも厳密に研究されて
それをありのままに生きるということにしているんですね
それはまあ私みたいな人が言ったっても
決して変えませんですけど
仏教でいうのはありのままに生きるっていうことではありません
猿で犬で豚でいいわけじゃないんですね
みんなありのままに生きてるんだからね
でもそれが正しいとね
ありのままに生きるっていうことは正しいとは思ってますけど
仏教で言ってるのはありのままに観察するっていうことであって
それは絶対視ない自分の妄想で観察する
自分を見たいままで見るということはしながら
生きることはありのままに生きると
仏教言ってのはそれ反対なんですね
ありのままで生きるんじゃないんだよと
物事を観察する場合はありのままに観察しなさいと
そこら辺は仏教と皆様の俗世間の人々のすごいこの世界変わっているところなんですね
まあどちらが正しいか分かりませんですけど
でありのままに生きていくと
仏教ではろくな結果にはなりませんと
危険だよということは言ってるんですね
ですから 自己管理しなさいと
特に心を管理しなさいと
智慧開発するためには
ありのままに見なさいと
それから ありのままに見るためにも
かなり厳しい訓練が必要なんです
ただ単にありのままに見られるわけじゃないんですね
ありのままに本当に見られるためには
一切固定概念と主観というのはね
全部綺麗になくさないと
ありのままに見られるわけではありません
ですから 私は昔からこう思ってるんだ
私は昔からこういう考え方だと言ったって
それはありのままではどうでもいいことなんですけども
だからといって仏教をねじ曲げてあげるわけにもいきませんし
だからまあ仏教で言っているありのままの生き方っていうのは
心にもう一切の固定概念のない
主観のない ありのままの見方なんですね
それにも大変な心の訓練
調教教育っていうものが必要なんです
それからこういうところで
この修行のありさまも説明していて
自分勝手で修行したっても
心育てをしても それが成り立たない
自分で心はどのように育てるべきかということは
自分で判断できるでしょうかということもありますしね
で 心ねじ曲がってる人は
それは直す方法も自分で考えちゃうと
その考え方はねじ曲がっているんですね
ですから ねじ曲がっている考え方で
じゃあ心育ちますよと言ったっていうのは
結局ねじ曲がったままになっちゃうんですね
それから我々のわがままで
気持ち次第に心が動いてくれるわけでもないし
物事には法則というものがございます
ですから 何にしても自分勝手に動くわけじゃない
人間というのは全て自分の意のままで
意思通りに動くことというふうには思ってはいます
それは世間の考え方 でも
実際の世界はそういうものではないんですね
物事は法則によって動いているんです
ですから 私の意見ということは全然もう認めないし
機能はしないというのは仏教で言ってることで
俗世間では自分の意見で自分の考え方で生きているんだ
それこそが素晴らしい生き方生き方だというのは
俗世間の思考で その点では仏教と世界の知恵っていうのはだいたい正反対なんです
仏教っていうのは 何一つ自分の希望
気持ち通りにはいかんと
で 意思は認めますけど
だからといって物事を意思通りにいくということじゃないんです
意思は認めているのはこの業の場合なんですね
行為の場合なんですね
手を上げたり 人を刺したり
人に何か言ったりするのは自分の意思
で言ってるんですね ですから
その自分の行為に責任を持たなくちゃいかない
自分の意思でやったんだから
持たなくても持ったってもどうでもいいことで
責任は付いているんです
そちらの自分の意思は関係ない
なくなっちゃうんですね
自分の意思で何かしたならば
もうとっくに自分の責任なんですね
私は責任持ちますよと
いや 私の責任ではありませんよと何言ったっても
そんな関係ないんです
自分が自分の意思で何か
何かしたり 喋ったり 考えたりしたならば
もうとっくにその結果が自分に付いてるんです
ですから それについて後悔したり
反省したり あらゆるいろいろごまかしをしたりしたっても
それはもう全然関係ないです
もうとっくに終わったことだから
それの結果が得なくちゃ受けなくてはいけなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから その意思は認めるんだけど
意思によって行為をする
ですから 自分が行為をしたことになります
自分に意志がなければ行為できないんだから
それで行為をしたならば
それで終わり もう結果がもう決まってる結果になるんだよと
だから自分の行為に自分で責任持ちますよと
そういう恐れたことを言わなくても
もう持つしか方法ないんです
もう逃げる方法はないんです
どう踏ん張っても業からは逃げられませんと
ですから 結局 自害式っていうのは働かないっていうことは
仏教の世界の一つの考え方なんですね
だからそれをわかって
また ではもう他人の意識で行動するんだぞとまた言ってる人々もいますけど
自分の意志で何も動かない場合は
他人の意思で動くはずがないんですけど
やっぱりそういう思考もあるんですけど
この理屈はちょっとわからないんですね
で まあ初期仏教ではそういう考え方はないんですけど
大乗仏教ではやっぱり他人の意思で自分の運命を定めるというふうには考えてますね
自分の意思でも何もできないんだったら
どうやって他人の意思でできるかっていうのはね
そこら辺は不思議でたまらないんですね
自分の力で成仏を悟ることはできない人が
他人の力で悟ると 何か深いわけがあると思いますけど
とにかくブッダの考え方とは全く正反対ということは正反対なんですね
ですから このこういう例えの中から見ると
もうこれはもうすごい頭の人々に言ってることよりも
一般的な人々のお釈迦様
これお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
こちら使ってますけど
アングリマールソンジャは
で サーリプッタソンジャのケースでも
その同じ芸が出てきますし
このサーリプッタソンジャも
ちっちゃな子供に瞑想しなさい
ちゃんと心育てなさいというところに使ってた例えで
ですから これはまあ子供に言った芸というふうな感じで取ってもいいし
だから 例えば水を管理する場合は
水道を作ったり イリゲーションというかね
田んぼに水を入れてほしいと
やっぱり水は水なりの法則を持ってるんですよ
水にも田んぼに入ってくれと言っても入ってくるわけじゃないんです
ただ作ってあげただけでも入ってくるわけじゃないんですよ
やっぱりそれなりに水の法則がありまして
どのように水が流れるかっていうことは
自然法則によって定めて決まってるんですね
そこで我々はその法則にのっとって管理するんです
法則を破ることはできないんです
それで田んぼに水が入るんです
で 田んぼに入った水をもう外へ出したいと思って
一番高いところに水の出口作ってあげたって
水は出ていかないんですね
水を出したければ やっぱり一番低いところの方で出口を作ってあげなくちゃいけない
なぜならば 水は低いところから出るということは決まっていて
誰にもそれ変えることはできません
例えば ではポンプを持ってきて
高いところから水を出すんだよと
ポンプは水道の高いところにしかつけられませんと言ったっても
法則を変えたわけじゃないんですね
私から見れば で 一応ポンプを開発した人は水の法則を変えましたと
だって下にある水はね
高いところにまで運ぶんではないかと
ですから 法則変えたんでしょうかね
私は法則変えてないと思いますね
だからポンプ必要になったのも
水はああいう風な自分の性質を持っているんだからなんですね
で ポンプで強引に水を上に運ぶだけです
だから我々バケツで水を運ぶ時でも同じ法則なんですよ
自分の力入れて わざわざと強引に上に上げるんだから
それで水の法則はもう変えましたと
ということにはなりません
とにかく水の法則を見た上でそういう管理をするんです
で 他の例にしても そういうふうなことで
矢を作るといったっても
矢は矢としてどんな特色かと一応決まって持っているし
枝は枝としてどんな特色が自分でまた持っているし
だからそこで法則を分かった上で自分の好きな形に変えることはできます
で ちょっと曲がっている枝をまっすぐにしたければ
ただ叩いただけでまっすぐになるわけじゃないし
引っ張っただけでまっすぐになるわけじゃないし
その植物の種類によって考えて
この植物だったらこういうふうに
こういうふうに工程をした方がまっすぐになるんだよということも一応決まってしまっちゃうんですね
そういうふうに 物事 すべての物事にはそれぞれの法則がありまして
で 自我 自我そのものも元々もないんだから
自我意志ということもないし
心には意志という法則もまたあるだけのことで
それは己の意志やといってもまたそれ違うんですね
それは心の機能の一つの原因
一つの原因法則だけのことで
それによって心は少々変わったりする
仏教でいう意志っていうのは
やっぱりこの行為を起こすためのエネルギーなんですね
ただ 行為を起こさせるエネルギーは意志でありますからね
ですから 瞑想する時でも
いろんな時は大変必要なことなんですね
何でも行為ですからね
だから行為をするためには意志の働きが必要であって
意志が強ければ強いほど
行為の強さも結果も大きくなってはきます
それで自分の希望通りにいくんだそうと思ったら
それはちょっと違いますよと
で こういう自分の希望通りではなくて
法則通りに物事は変化していくんですね
だから我々は法則さえ知っておけばいいということで
それで心の場合でも 心には心の法則というものは当然ながらある
すべてのものには法則があるんだから
心にも法則がある その法則を知った上で
その心はどのように管理して成長させればよろしいかということは
人々は知って それを知っている人は賢者というし
それで心を育てる ですから
私たちの自己本位で自分本位で考え出した何かの方法で心が成長するんだということはないんです
いろんな方法を試したところで
一つうまくいったんだそうと言ったら
その方法でいくそうではなくて
賢者はそこでなんでこの方法でうまくいったんでしょうかということは勉強して
この法則を発見するんですね
ですから そこで何ものの中にもある法則を発見するということは
また一つ仏教で言ってる特徴なんですね
で 法則を発見するんだから
信仰やらね 迷信的な信じるということは要らなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから あの人もやったんだから
この人もやったんだから
では私もやるぞということは信仰なんですね
そういうこともあまり仏教ではないんですね
法則を発見するんだよということで
物事の法則を発見する
法則を発見すると 他人にも教えてあげることはできます
例えば 自分がたまたま何かの修行方法で心が清らかになったとしますね
それで自分がたまたまやった修行法は
みんなにばらまいて教えてあげたっても
みんなうまくいくわけじゃないんですね
それでなんで自分がたまたまうまくいったんだろうというふうな
この過程の中にあった
この心の法則という真理の法則をわかって理解してもらって
それだったその法則を発見してしまえば
他の人々にも同じ法則ですから
そこで教えてあげることはできますね
ですから お釈迦様がなんで偉大なる指導者と言えますかというと
この法則の発見者だからなんですね
あらゆる物事の法則を発見しましたから
偉大なる指導者にはなっているんですね
ですから ブッダから教えてもらって
他人に指導する人々は偉大なる指導者にはなりません
だから 自分で法則を発見しているわけじゃないんだから
その分能力は少ないんですね
自分で発見する人と発見したものを勉強する人とはちょっと訳が違いますからね
だから 発見した人のノウハウというか
テクニックというのは
これはすごいもんなんですね
勉強してもらう人の能力っていうのは
まあそれほどあるわけじゃないんですね
勉強しているんだから間違っているわけじゃないんですが
そんなにすごい上手いということでもないんですね
そういうことだから ブッダが偉大なる指導者で
ブッダの教えを勉強してわかって教える人々は
決して偉大なる指導者ということになりませんね
そういう法則にしてみたら
だいたいそういうことはございます
そこでポイントとして理解してほしいのは
このどこにでも この世の中で自分の意思というか気持ちというか希望ということは機能しないということなんですね
何一つも 例えばご飯食べるの
自分の意思でしょうと思っているでしょうね
それで自分の好物たくさんあると
これ明日もう二日分三日分あるんだと
でもこれは気持ちが悪いもので
今日中に食べなくちゃいけない好物だから好きでたまらない
三日分がある では 三日分も食べてみる
食べてあげるぞと思っても
自分の希望通りにはいかないんですね
人に食べられる量はもう一応決まっている
そうすると 余分にもらった二日分はどうしてもゴミ箱に捨てなくちゃいけないんですね
だから たくさん倍食べるぞと思っても食べられるわけじゃないんですね
では じゃあ私は食べないでいるぞと思ったっても
それ自分勝手ではできません
人間がお腹が空いたら食べなくてはならないんですね
そんなに世界で存在ですごい存在であるならば
それぐらいの自己管理できるでしょ？できるはずがないんですよ
お腹が空いたら食べなくちゃいけないし
食べるにしてもそのその量とか何とかとか
もう自然法則によって全部定まる定まられるというかね
どうにもならんことなんですね
ですから そこら辺は理解するとすごく頭が良くなるんですね
で 仏教から見れば でも理解しないで
それに逆らって踏ん張るということは
俗世間の生き方なんですね
とにかく逆らって踏ん張ってやってみるそうと逆らってやろうと思ったっても
結局それの場合 その場合でも法則に則らないと
いっぱい食べて食べて
それでも痩せる方法とかみんな発見しようとするんですけどね
だから普通の法則はもうあまり食べると太るということ法則なんですね
それで人間のわがままっていうのは
食べたい放題食べたいんだと
しかし太りたくはないんだと
で それでいろんな薬やらね
いろんなものを探したり
調べたり 食べ物のいろんなことと
なんとか食品 美容食品やらね
ダイエット食品やらとかもいっぱい作ったりはする
では ダイエット食品作る人々は何をやっているかというと
やっぱり法則を逆らうことはできないんですね
ですから もう食べても食べても痩せる薬がありますよと言っても
やっぱり法則破ったぞと
すごいぞということはできません
法則破ってるわけじゃないんですよ
だいたいダイエット食品というのは
お腹に入る食べ物はお腹に吸収しないようにする
ですから このまあ 食べたことはないんですけど
わからないんですけど
食べ物を食べて食べる時はおいしく感じますけど
食べたものはお腹でそのまま硬いものになって残ると
食べた時の楽しみよりは倍も気持ち悪いんですね
一番この消化不良状態ほど気持ち悪いことっていうのは全くないほどなんですね
ですから この美味しいものをパクパク食べたいという気持ちで
こうやってダイエット食品を食べたりする
先に食べて それからご飯食べる
一回はうまくいくんだけど
一回食べた瞬間からおそらくお腹の中でこれはもう硬い状態になって
細かい分子にならないで
お腹でもうほとんど消化しないというかね
それで胃の中で腸の中でそれはもうずっと持っていくということは
もうかなりきついと思いますね
だからそれで嫌になっちゃって
もう食べるもの見たくても嫌やと
そういうことになる可能性ありますね
だから結局いっぱい食べて痩せたいということではなくて
もう食べるの 先ほどさえ苦痛になるんじゃないかなととは思いますけどね
それで痩せたりする可能性ありますけど
それでまた栄養分が足らなくなったりして
また体が壊れたりするとかもありますから
そう簡単に私たちの希望通りにうまくいくわけじゃないということだけは事実なんですね
そういうふうなことで
このいつでもこの法則があるということと
法則が知っておく 法則を発見しておく
何のためかというと この不幸な状態をいい方向へ変えるためなんですね
だから法則はどうにもならんということは
定められているんだということは
暗い もうどうしようもないいいやといういい加減な思考ではありません
いいやという感じで全て投げ捨てて
もう失望感で もう怒りで
憎しんで苦しむための話じゃないんです
法則を知った人が管理できる
法則を知らない人にとっては
もう運命で定められたままで苦しむしか方法ないんですね
で 自分がちょっとうまくいったんだからといって
自分の意思で 自害式で何でもできそうと思ったら
これも誤解のいいところで
自害式で我がままで行ったわけじゃなくて
法則に則っていい方向へ行ったんだぞということなんですね
で その偈の意味はそういうふうなもので
次にこのアングリマーラ尊者がこのお釈迦様に自分をどのように調教されたかということをね
お釈迦様の偉大性というか
偉大なるお釈迦様のこの偉大なる指導者だからね
で 調教丈夫というね 言葉がありますからね
アヌットロプリセダンマサーラティ
この上のない調教丈夫やと
だからもう人を調教するためには
お釈迦様ほど人はいませんということでね
ですから このこういうこの九百九十九人の人を殺して
もっとたくさん殺したみたいですけどね
一応その指を自分の指を首輪にして自分の首にかけてた人でしょ
だから人が見たら あ じゃあ指一本やということに思っていた人なんですね
人間がとわからないんですね
頭がおかしくなっちゃって
人がもう一本指がありますと
自分の首輪に 三見たらあ
今日は指指三本だと それしかわからないんですね
[終始背景音楽]だから動物なんかはね
猿とかね 木から木へで飛んで行ってっちゃうと
果物と あ 果物の餌がある
餌があるんだと それしかわからないんだからね
それは餌であるかないか
それで植物は何なのかとか
それはどうでもいいんだよ
猿にとっては この植物種類とかわかりません
知ってるのは自分にとって食べられるものかないかっていうぐらいのだけのことです
ですから アングリマーラ尊者にしても
男か女か子供かお年寄りそれわからない
指一本やと 指一本だけは確かにあるんだからね
で 十本あるんだけど 彼が一本しか取らないんですね
それぐらいの人を瞬時に心変えてもらったんですね
だからアングリマーラさんも知っていたんですね
こんな悪人だから 自分をね
もう自分を立ち直るためにすると言ったら
おそらく無理でしょうと
一人二人殺しちゃうと
もうもうもう終身刑になるか
あるいは首を飛んじゃうし
もういわゆるもう立ち直る見込みさえもないんですね
人を殺しちゃうと 法律的にはその人の首も飛んでしまっちゃうでしょうね
ですから 立ち直る見込みは全くない人で
これまた大量殺人者で
それくらいの人でも お釈迦様は育ててみせたんですね
完全たる解脱を得た人にして見せたんですね
だからお釈迦様はどんな罰を与えたかと
どんな厳しいことをさせたかと
この人は逆立ちさせて何ヶ月間でもぶら下げておいたかとかね
そういうふうに もうなんかこのもう叩き直すってことだからね
厳しいことをしなくちゃあかんですけどね
でもそういうこと何一つしなかったんですね
だからそこで すごく親切な一言でお釈迦様にその人々を育てることできたんですね
ですから 人を導くことはもうこの上のない能力を持っている
もう誰にもその能力はないということも確かなんですね
だから次の偈でこのお釈迦様を褒め称えるんですね
ダンデーナ エケー ダマヤンティ アンクセーヒ カサーヒチェ アダンデーナ アサッテーナ アハン ダントゥー ミターディナー
ダンデーナ エケー ダマヤンティ
ダンダっていうのは棒を持ってスティックを持って叩くということなんですね
ダンダっていうのはパニッシュメント罰という意味でも訳せますけど
学者の訳は何でしたっけ？ある者たちは棒により
やっぱり 一応スティックやら棒やら何か持って
もうもう叩いたりして大人しくしてもらう
わがまま言わないようにしてもらうという
エケー ダマヤンティ ある人々はそうやって叩いて叩いて大人しくさせなくてはいけないんですよ
だいたいこの場合はもう人間も同じことはありますけど
動物なんか調教する場合はね
言うことを聞かないと
動物はわがままで自分本位で行動しちゃうと
もうスティックを持ってピシピシと叩く
叩くともう言うことを聞いてくれると
アンクセーヒ アンクセは？アンクセは一応こうやって曲がっていて
先にちょっと尖っていて
それで捕まるところあって
だからアンクサっていうのはゾウを使う時使う武器なんですね
で そうやって曲がってます
先は 日本のゾウでも動物園で見たら
みんなの腰に短いのがかけてます
そちらちゃんと曲がってるんですね
で それはこのアンクサなんですね
で タイやらミャンマーやら自分の国でもゾウがすごい背が高いんだから
結構長い棒にこれつけてるんですね
そう それで引っかかって止まってもらう
それを体につけるとすぐゾウが止まるんですね
で またまっすぐの尖ったものが二つあります
いっぺんに 一つは曲がっていて
一つはまっすぐで シャープ部分が体につけるとゾウがすごく嫌がるんですね
だから引っ張る時は曲がったところは必要し
引っかかって引っ張っちゃうし
で 例えば足とか上げろと言いたい場合は
言いたい場合はもうまっすぐのところを足に入れちゃうと
足上げてくれるんですね
アンクソは必ずしもゾウ使いの武器なんです
武器ですね それだけで一本だけでゾウは随分おとなしくなってくれます
子供のゾウの場合はあれは使わないんですけどね
子供はこれ怖いものやともわからないし
で いい加減わがままだから
子供の象っていうのはね
かなりやんちゃだからね
やんちゃのはいいんだけど
それはすごい怖い武器だよともわからないんですね
ですから 子供の象調教する時
それ引っ張ったりさせたりしちゃうと
子供は怪我するんですよ
その場合は細いスティックとか使っちゃうんです
まあ子供の象っていうのは
そんなにもいたずらやんちゃですけどね
言うこと聞かないっていうことはないんですけどね
仕事はしないんですね
いくら言っても むちゃくちゃにする
時々親を見て仕事をするんですけどね
ちょっと見てまた全部むちゃくちゃにしたり
普通ついてしちゃうという
その時怒っちゃえば それだけではもう何やってるんですかと怒ればもうすぐ聞いてくれるんですね
どんどん大きくなってくると
もうちゃんと武器を使わないと
アンクさ 次にカサー カサーっていうのは鞭ですね
鞭は大体馬に使うんですからね
そこで棒かこうか あるいは鞭か
もう何かの武器で動物を調教する
だから罰っていうのは必要でしょうね
昔からも だから今の人間にはもう罰なんかなくなっちゃうと
やっぱり調教っていうのはね
管理っていうのはできなくなってくるしね
そこでアダンデーナアサッテーナ
アダンデーナ棒もなくアサッテーナ武器もなく
アダンデーナアサッテーナっていうのは冒険に寄らすというぐらいの意味で
アハン私はダントウ調教されたと
私が調教されたである
ンヒっていうのはアンヒっていうのはであると
されたのである ターディナ
で ターディナーの訳はこちらはかかるお方はという風にもありますけど
ターディっていうのはその意味
そのかかかるお方の意味は分かりません
この方はというぐらいの意味でしょうね
おそらく ターディナっていうのは
これは意味が 訳はおそらく違うとターディというお釈迦様に使う用語なんですね
いわゆるもうものすごいもうできたというね
敬語ですけど ターディっていうのはお坊さんたちも使いますけど
例えばこの修行完成したというね
ターディという名詞であります
修行完成した 落ち着いている人
心穏やかになった人 ターディといえば
ものすごく安定して落ち着いている人という意味で使っているんです
ターディン こちらはその如くはやっぱりこちらかかると書いているんだからね
[背景音楽]まあこの訳も一意味がありますけどね
だからね まあややこしいよね
このもし PTS にはその意味がないかもしれませんし
パーリ経典協会の辞書に
だからまあその意味で行かなくちゃいけない
まあ原文はどうであろうとも
誰かさんが決めたら まあその意味で行かなくちゃいけないという
まあ普通はターディという意味はね
まあ我々知ってるパーリ語で
学者のパーリ語ではなくて
間違ってるパーリ語だったら
まあ一応心落ち着いてる
安定したっていう意味なんです
もうターディンというのは
まあターディサッという意味でも使えますけどね
だからかかるお方にという意味合いはしっかり意味は取れるんですよ
もう心落ち着いた人といえばブッダのことで
ブッダに調教されたのであると
だから私たちはもう普通の仏教徒として勉強するときは
もうターディ あるいはターディンということである
すぐ釈迦尊という意味で取っているんですけどね
ガヤガヤとイギリスでどう考えているんでしょうかとか
それは困った 困っちゃったとかね
イギリス人がそう思っているんだから
やっぱり我々の伝統は間違っているんだとか
そこまではあまり心配しませんですけどね
ですから この学者の意見と
いろんなところで仏教徒の人々の意見も違うところも結構あります
で まあそういうことで
お釈迦様の人を育てる方法というのはすごいということで
これはお釈迦様を褒め称える偈なんですね
ダンデーナエーケーダマヤンティアンクセーヒカサーヒキャアダンデーナアサッテーナアハンダントーミターディナ
私を調教されたのであると
いわゆる私が悟られたのであるということなんですね
調教されたということは
もうこれっきり 限り もう全然悪いことはしない
心はもう完璧になりましたからね
次の偈 アヒンサコーティメーナーマンヒンサカッサプレーサトーアッジャハンサッチャナーモーミーナナンヒンサーミカンチナンアヒンサコーティメーナーマン
メー 私の ナーマン 名前はアヒンサコー
アヒンサコーでしたと
アヒンサコーっていうのは害を与えないという意味でね
無害者という意味なんですね
私の名前は無害者であったと
ヒンサカッサプレーサトー
しかし プレー 昔はヒンサカッササトー
害を 害ばっかり 他人に害ばっかりさせていたにも関わらず
私の名前は無害者であったと
やっていることと名前は正反対でしたと
サトーっていうのは何かやっていながら
あるいはやっているにも関わらずというふうな意味に訳するとき使います
かって害者であった私に無害者という名前あり
まあその訳で こちらでまあプレーサトーっていうのは
まあいたにも関わらずということで
プレー 昔は害者で まあ害を与える人でいたにも関わらず
名前だけは無害者でしたと
アッジャアハン アッジャアハンっていうのはアッジャアハン
アッジャ 今日 今 アハン
私が サッチャナーモ サッチャ
正しい 本物というね 真理ということで
ナーマ 今は私の名前はその通り正しいんだと
今は正しい名前を持っているんだと
なぜならば ナナンヒンサーミカンチナン
ナ しません ナン 私は ヒンサーミ
害を与えることは絶対しません
カンチナン 誰にでも いかなる生命にでも
私はもう全然害を与えることはしません
ですから 私の名前はもうそのごとくであると
真理であると 私は今こそアヒンサカだよと
無害者であるであると
いわゆるやっと名前通りになりましたと
前はまるっきり違うと
そこでまた自分の経歴を言うんですね
よく正確的にできた人っていうのは
何のことなく自分の過去っていうのは隠すことなく言うんです
[外国語]チョロアハン
プレアーシン アングリマーローティヴィッスト
ウイヘマーノマホーゲーナ
ブッダンサランマーガマン
チョロアハン プレアーシン
アングリマーローティヴィッスト
ウイヘマーノマホーゲーナ
ブッダンサランマーガタン
アハン プレチョロアーシン
アハン 私はプレ 昔チョロ大泥棒という
チョロという泥棒なんですけど
この場合は犯罪者か何とかです
共謀者とかね 教則でありましたと
アーシンというのはありましたと
私は昔は教則でありました
アングリマーロ アングリマーラという名前の
で アングリマーラっていうのはやっぱりある程度で訳しないと意味は取れません
アングリっていうのは指のこと
マーラっていうのは首輪ですね
だから指輪というね 指輪って言っちゃダメですね
指の首輪ですね だから指の首輪ということで
もうその人の名前でしたね
アングリマーラ 私は昔はアングリマーラという風にヴィッスタっていうのは知られている
有名になっていたんだと
そこでウイヘマーノマホーゲーナ
マホーガっていうのは大洪水ですね
ウイヘマーナっていうのはそれにもう流されてしまったと
そこで私はいくらもう教則でえらく威張って指の首輪も首にかけて偉そうにいたんだけど
大洪水にも流されてしまったと
大洪水にもう入っちゃうと
もうどうにもならんだからね
流されてしまっちゃって
ブッダに帰依しましたと
大洪水って何なのかね
そこら辺はっきりしないんですね
そこでターディーっていうのはかかるお方というふうな役割ましたけど
注釈書では私の意味で注釈しているんですよ
イッハーニッハーディーすニッディカーレーナ
イッハーニッハーっていうのは人のためになるもの
人をダメにするもの それにそういうことについて明確にちゃんと知っているんだからターディーと言うんだよと
そこでこの五つの特色でブッダに特色というか特徴というかね
五つの意味でブッダにお釈迦様にターディーというんだよと
イッハーニッテーターディー
ワンターヴィーターディー
チャッターヴィーターディー
ティンナーヴィーターディー
イッハーニッテーワンターヴィーチャッターヴィーティンナーヴィー
そういう五つ 一応五つの意味は書いてあって
そういうことで そのごとくになるんだからということで
ターディーラックナパットラックナッパッテーナサッターラ
そこで次の偈はない ないかな
大洪水には注は書いてないんですね
この大洪水に流されてブッダに消えしまったというのもね
大洪水といえば もう一応お釈迦様の教えぐらいでも
注釈入れればいいんだからね
お釈迦様の教えにもうぶつかれてしまっちゃって
もうどうにもならなくなっちゃって
もう投げされてしまったと
だから注釈書でもこちらで大洪水っていうのはブッダの説法であるとかなんとかあった方が良かったんではないかなと思いますけど
まあ結局大洪水っていうのはお釈迦様との対話でしたから
もうお手上げで もうもうブッダに帰依するしか方法ないんですね
それには逆らうことはできない
できないんだから ですから
まあ自分にはもう大洪水にもう入って飲まれてしまうと
もうどうにもならんということですね
いくら高速であろうと
もうどうにもならんと
それでブッダに帰依しましたと
ローヒタパーニプレアーシンアンゴリマーローティヴィッストーサラナーガマナンパッサバワネッティサムハター
そこでまた自分の過去ローヒタパーニプレアーシン
昔ローヒタパーニ 血まみれて生まれた手でしたと
以前にも人殺していたんだからね
で アンゴリマーローティヴィッストー
それだけではなくて 名前までアンゴリマーでした
それすごいこの人々に付けたもうあだ名でしたからね
ひどいこの非難的なあだ名でしたからね
そこでサラナーガマナンパッサ
パッサっていうのは見よサラナーガマナン
ブッダに帰依すること
ブッダに帰依したことも
それは見よと パッサ見なさいよと
私はブッダに帰依してしまったと
バワネッティサムハタ
それ見よっていうのはどれほど意味があるかと見てみなさいと
ブッダに帰依することは
バワネッティサムハタ
輪廻に際し バワっていうのは存在
輪廻のことで ネッティっていうのは束縛で煩悩のことで
サムハタ全部なくなりましたと
ネッティっていうのは注釈書の訳がありまして
この牛の場合はね 首にロープをかけてあっちこっち引っ張って連れて行くんですね
そういう風に人間の心に紐をかけられて輪廻転生させちゃうんだと
そういう力にバワネッティと言うんだ
だから渇愛のことですね
心に渇愛あるんだから
我々は死んでもまた生まれ変わって
また生まれ 死んでまた生まれ変わってという
もう六道の中でずっと生まれ変わってしまうんですね
限りなく だから生きていきたい
生きていきたい もっと欲しい
もっと欲しいという この渇愛っていうのはずっと心の中にあるんですね
だからこのもっと欲しいというそのことが
我々にもうどんどんどんどん輪廻転生させる
その状態がネッティ  だから渇愛
ネッティですよ うん ネッティといえばもう一応ね
まあいい まあ語源はどうでもいいんですけど
渇愛の同義語なんです
バワネッティといえば
ネッティだけでは意味がわからなくなります
ネッティだけだったらみんなすごい混乱しちゃうんで
ネッティっていうのはネットルっていう言葉から出てきて
導くっていう意味なんですね
だから導くものっていう意味になってしまうんですね
そこを意味も取って紐にしているんですね
ロープにしているんですね
導くというよりも引っ張る
それも一つの導きだからね
あまり格好ある導きじゃないんですけどね
で 首に鎖をかけられて
それで導きと それとこれバワネッティ
バワに導く 存在に導く
輪廻に導く 輪廻に導くって言えば言えばタンハであった渇愛なんですね
そこでブッダに帰依したこれはこの力見よ
バワネッティサムハタ
バワネッティが消えましたよと
これすごいもんだよと
これはもうそれほどすごいことはないんだからね
渇愛消えたんだよと ターディサンカンマンカットワーナバフドゥッグガティガミナンプットーカンマヴィパケーナアノノーブンジャミブージャナン
ターディサンカンマンカットワーナ
ターディサンっていうのはこのような
これから説明するようなという意味で
カンマンカットワーナ
業を犯してしまう いわゆる悪業ですけどね
こんなこれぐらい業を犯して
バフ たくさん ドゥッグガティガミナン
もう苦しい世界に生まれ変われる
いわゆる地獄に落ちて
あまりにも苦しむほどのたくさんたくさん悪行を犯してしまったのに
プットーカンマヴィパケーナは繋がりはどうしますかね
そこでこの地獄に落ちて苦しむ業をたくさんしましたよと
次にカンマヴィパケーナプットー
カンマヴィパカーっていうのは業の果報ですね
で 業の結果ですね 業の結果にプットーっていうのは振られてっていう
だからそこら辺ちょっとわかりにくくなるんですね
不幸になる地獄に落ちる罪をたくさん犯してしまったと
業の果報に触れていると
ひどい目に遭ったという意味になっちゃいますけどね
だから私は注釈書の解釈も
それは後から説明しますけど
おそらく振られたならばというふうにね
業の果報に触れたならば
大変な苦しみを受けるはずのたくさん悪業を犯してしまったというふうに訳した方が
ちょっと論理的にはつなげますけど
でもパーリ語では文法的にそういうふうに訳するために振られたならばというふうに訳するためにはプットーではダメなんですね
これは格分子だからね
だからサチプッテイエとかなんとかとかにしないと出てこないんですね
とにかくこの偈だから
このチャンダスというメーターというものがありますから
そう簡単に言葉を変えることはできません
ですから おそらく昔この偈を作った時はプットカマウパケーナといえば
文字数がぴったしメーターにはめるんですね
ですから そうしちゃったと思いますけど
それで意味がわからなくなっちゃうということにもなるんですね
カマウパカーニプットー
カマウパカーニというのは業の果報
業の結果 業の結果に触れたんだよという格分子で
業の果報に触れちゃったならば
ひどい目に遭うんだけど
アンリマーラ長老が もう千人飛ばして殺しちゃったんだから
だからそれで注釈書はこの業の果報に触れたということは
マッガチェタナイプットー
自分が修行して悟りを開くでしょう
だから悟り開く心が道心と果心とつなんですね
道と果にするんですね
マッガチッタパラチッタと
修行していると 例えばヨルカだったらヨルドーシンという心が生まれるんですね
ヨルドーシンという心が生まれた瞬間で
ヨルカシンという家心が生まれてくるんですね
道と結果 道と結果と だから一緒なんですね
それから瞬間で もう本人も気づかない
どちらが道心 どちらが果心かという
次の心ですからね それぐらい早く道心
だから道心っていうのは即世間の心なんですよ
即世間と言ってるか言わない
その道心が生まれると
煩悩が全部じりじりと消えてなくしてしまうんです
だから煩悩をなくす働き持っている心には道心という
で なくした次の心にはどうせどうせ煩悩がないんですね
それには果心と言うんですね
だから100年の修行は計算しません
この修行じりじり出てくる悟る瞬間の悟ったという瞬間の前の心に
それはマッガチッタ それは道心ですね
パラチッタ果心ですね
そこで煩悩なくなるのは
その悟る心の一つ下にある道心で煩悩がなくなって
次に悟った心が生まれるんです
そこでカムマ・ヴィパーカにプッタっていうのは
このマッガチッタで 道心で
もう全部業の果報に触れてしまったと
まあ無理はあるんですけど
説明には 一応まあ ただ表面的にこの偈を見ると
まあカムマ・ヴィパーカに業の果報に触れたと言っちゃうと
悪業のカムマに触れたことになっちゃうんですね
そうするとひどい目に遭うことになるんですね
ですから 注釈書 これは悪業のカムマに触れたわけじゃなくて
修行して道心で もうカムマに
業にもう立ち向かったと
いわゆる立ち向かってないんですけど
一応煩悩が消えてしまったんですね
それで業の果報はもう全部もうチャラになっちゃうんですね
今まで人殺した業が全部もう
もうチャラ もうないということになってしまっちゃうんですね
とにかくアンリマール
このストーリーで流れでいうのは
アンリマール尊者がもう九百九十九人人を殺して
もう地獄に落ちる運命でもう決まっていたんですが
もう修行して悟ってしまっちゃったんですね
悟ったあの瞬間で 全部業に触れて終わった
触れたということは 業はもう終了したということなんですね
ですから もう全部これから苦しみであるはずでした
苦しみであろうと思っていたあの業のあの巨大なエネルギーは全部もう風船に張りさしたような感じで
全部もうチャラになってしまったんですね
もう罪人ではありません
もう完全たる聖者なんです
あんた一週間前人殺しではなかった？と
それでどうしたというんでしょうかという立場なんです
ですから いかに悟ることは大事かということなんですね
誰が あんた一週間も人を殺していたのではないか
それでどうしたというんですかと
もう関係ないと だから全くもう関係もない
もう影響も受けないということで
アノノ・ブンジャミ・ボージャナン
アノの果報に触れられて
負債を持たず食を取ると
で 負債はないんだと 今ご飯食べてますけど
負債はないんだと こちらで言ってるのは
もう我々の生き方っていうのはやっぱり負債ばっかしなんですよ
で 出家したっても負債だよと
というのはひとつまだ仏教の厳しい見方なんですね
それはひとつ ちょっとしたモラル的な教えですし
そんなに真剣に あの 教理学的なところではないとは思いますけど
やっぱり まあ例えば在家の場合は
人が仕事をしてご飯食べているのは
それは当たり前で まあ人から物を奪って食べるんじゃないよと
自分の努力で頑張って仕事をして食べなさいというね
自分の業ではないかと
だからこちらで生まれたのは自分の業で生まれたんだからね
まあそれで自分で仕事をしてご飯を食べているというのは
それは別に問題はないんですね
だからといって私は負債で食べて負債なしに何も負債はないんだということは言えないんですよ
例えば出家にしても もう托鉢に出たら
誰かがちょっとご飯をポイと落としたりする
まあそれはまああげる側も別にそんなにもう借金してあげるわけでもないし
何か期待してるわけでもないし
まあだから何の貸し借りもない
ただ食べ物でしょ で それ食べたんだからといって負債はなしとはないんだと
というのは厳しくモラル的に仏教では言うんですね
あんた貸しをしているんだと
これどういうことでしょうかね
自分で仕事して もう米買ってきてご飯炊いて
これは貸しだよと言っちゃうと
やりきれないね でも貸しになるんだと
ご飯食べるだけじゃなくて
一日中生きることは全部食べたりいろんなことをしているで
全て貸しやと それはどういうことかというと
我々の心はもう煩悩で煩悩しかないでしょうに
貪瞋痴しかないでしょうに
だからもう仕事をして儲かったご飯かもしれませんだけど
ああ 美味しいなとか欲が生まれるんですよ
なんて幸せですかと 私は
こういう美味しいご飯を食べられて
高価な服を着られて もう居心地のいい家に住まれてという風に
もうすごく欲が出てくるんですよ
それが負債なんです それで新しい業を作っちゃうんですよ
かわいそうに 過去でいいことをしたんだから
過去でいいことをしたんだから
今すごいごちそうを食べています
そこでなんて美味しいごちそうですかと
と思うでしょうね そう思わなきゃ幸福を感じないんですよ
例えば過去でいいことするでしょ
それは幸福になるためにいいことをするんですよ
そこで幸福な人っていうのは
ごちそうを食べながら
これ本当に美味しくていいな
なんと美味しいですか
なんと美しいですかとか
その喜びなんですよ 結局は
まあなんだつまらないということになっちゃうと
もう喜ばないんですよ
例えばブランドのカバンはあるんだけど
ちっとデザイン古いんだからつまらないと置いておくと幸福を感じないでしょ
感じないんです そこで自分のブランドのカバンは特注なんとか品で
限定品で十個しか作ってないんだと
このなんとか会社が それ番号まで振ってるんだと
8番とか9番とかね そうするとこれはもうもう競りに出しちゃうといくらでも高く売れるんだと
これすごい もうそれで手に持っていくとえらい幸福感じるんでしょ？それが幸福で
このデザインはもう売れないんだよと
もう売ったと 売った時は 20万円でしたけど
今もう 1万ですよと言っちゃうと不幸を感じちゃうんです
ですから 過去でいいことをしたら
今幸福を味わいます 今ごちそうを食べています
そこでなんて美味しいでしょうかと
なんて私は幸せでしょうかと
こういう珍しい食べ物を食べているんだよと
この店だったら 1年前から予約しないと入れてくれないんだと
それで私の場合 特別配慮させていただいて
すぐ入れてくれたんだと
電話一本で なんかディプロマティック気分で
皇太子気分でご飯食べてるでしょうね
それでこの上ない喜びを感じているんですよ
それで 残念なことに それが仇になるんですよ
それですごい欲 心の中で煩悩いっぱい生まれてくるんですね
なんて幸せなものかと私はということが煩悩になって
それが悪業になったんだ
払えと その分の悪業は
だから欲で食べてるんだから
その食べてる瞬間瞬間で悪いことしてるんです
だから輪廻っていうのはするもんじゃないんだと
輪廻もいいんじゃないかと
天国に生まれるは もし徳でも積んでおけば
日本に生まれたっても億万長者で生まれるわとかね
悪くないんだと 輪廻するのを
とみんな思ってるんですよ
例えば今世で短命で死んだっても
ちょっといいことをしておけば
来世で自分は長寿でいられるんだからいいんじゃないかと
だから一生懸命普通の仏教の人々は徳を積むんですよ
輪廻が幸福にありますようにと
でもそこでまたすごい落とし穴があるんです
それ 誰かが作った落とし穴ではないんですよ
法則な そこは一番たちが悪いんで
法則だからどうにもならんですからね
だって自分が十万円で買った服をね
誰かにこれ去年のデザインでしょうとかね
一昨年のデザインでしょうと言われると
不幸でしょうに  なんかすごい
服は服だからどうったことはないんだけど
やっぱりわざと高い服をデザインのメーカー製品を着ているのは
その分喜びたいんだからでしょうに
それで誰かがこれを一昨年のデザインですよとか言われちゃうと
全部ドーンとあの幸福感がもう消えてしまうんですね
それでその もしその人は
あーすごい新しいデザインですね
まだ日本にも入ってないんですね
このスタイルはと誰かに言われると
すごくやったぞという気持ちになるんですね
私には親戚はフランスにいるんだから
もうすぐ送ってくれたんだから
もうやったぞということで
それが本当に幸福感なんですが
でも幸福感を味わうためには
高慢やら欲やら嫉妬やら
もういろいろ煩悩がないと幸福感が感じないんですよ
だから人間の幸福というのは
結局欲か嫉妬か競争心かどちらかの煩悩なんですね
怒りか だから 欲と怒り
競争心で 嫉妬で行動すると
それが罪なんですね ですから
いつでも幸福になった人は次にすぐドーンと陥ってしまうというふうには
もう輪廻の法則がそういうふうになっているんです
そこで法則を知っている人がもう落ちれないように気をつけると
だから仏教徒たちが回向するときは
回向じゃなくて この回向の文句と自分の回向にもありますからね
私はこういうみんなこの
まあこういう功徳によって
私はどこに生まれても貧乏にはならないように
豊かで恵まれて 財産何から何まで恵まれて生まれるようにと輪廻転生するならばと言うんですよ
言っちゃうと幸福になるでしょ
それと落とし穴があること知ってるんですね
知って 何に恵まれても
物に執着せず お布施うんうんなどをして
さらにパーラミタですか
完成できるようにというふうに自分の回向をするんですよ
そこで落とし穴からなんとか脱出しようと
そこで この徳は功徳はそうやっていっぺんに解脱できないならばね
じわじわと解脱の方向へ自分を押されてくれるようにというふうに
ずいぶんややこしい回向の文句なんです
単純で幸福でありますようにということじゃないんです
テーラワーダの仏教徒たちの回向文句は
結構長い 例えばお布施行事の場合は
このお坊さんたちがこの信者さんにややこしいんだから
この代わり回向文句をお坊さんが言うんですよ
信者さんがよく聞いていて
最後にサードゥと賛成すればそれで十分やと
で それは十分五分はかかります
ずっと回向文句終わるまで
どれぐらい長いかと かなり長い
もうまた言葉難しくて
サミたちがすごい苦労して暗記するんですけどね
結構長いいろいろ文句もあります
だからそれは別にどうったことはないんですけど
やっぱりその法則のからくりっていうのはみんなよく知っていて
日常生活でよく使っているんですね
そこら辺は学問的に勉強しても全然発見できないところなんです
日常生活でみんなも知っていることで
だから幸福に 不幸になるより幸福になるのはもう間違いでしょうし
貧乏になるよりは豊かになるのは当たり前
もういいことであって
だからといって それは完全安全というわけではありませんと
貧乏の人よりも豊かな人の方が罪深いんだと
怖いんだと だから貧乏になりたくなりたない
いえ 貧乏になりたくないという
貧乏にはなりたくないんだけど
豊かにはなりたいんだけど
豊かさもそれほどありがたい
完全安全状態ではないんだと
心は汚れるんだと 智慧がもう鈍くなるんだと
欲に溺れちゃうんだと
私こそ世界一や誰にももう負けないぞという気持ちになるんだよと
そうやって金持ちになっちゃうと
いろいろお金ばらまいて悪いことをしたり言ったり
もう必ず見ていくと 世の中見たってもそうでしょうに
豊かになればなるほど
恵まれれば恵まれるほど
精神的にはジリジリと堕落して悪行ばっかりするんですよ
そこであの悪行をするときに限って幸福感感じるという
もうひどいカラクリなんですよ
悪行をしないと全然幸福感を感じないんですね
業の働きはそういう働きなんです
そこでアヌヌという定義の説明ですから
ですから我々は過去でいいことをして
それから今世でもよく仕事をして
しっかり生きていて 豊かになってご飯を食べている
誰にも借りがないんだと言ったっても
借りを作っているんだと
あなた方に借りがないんだと
我々にとって借りがないんですよ
例えば人が豊かでご飯を食べていると
あなたに借りもないんですから
私に関係ないんだからね
でも自分で作っちゃうんです
貸しというかね そこが問題であると
ですから この負債がないと言ったっても
他人に負債があるという意味じゃないんです
自分が仕事をしてもらった給料でご飯食べたら
これはもう別にもう会社にも負債あるわけじゃないで仕事してあげたんだから
これは自分が儲かったお金は自分のお金なんですけど
でもそれを使うと自分が負債をする
だから使わなくたっても同じこと
使っても同じことで これは大事にしまってよそうと思ったら
それまた欲になってしまって
それで負債になるんですね
欲が欲を作ったと では使ってご飯食べて遊ぶそうと思ったら
それで喜び喜んで欲作っちゃうんだから負債になると
では何か方法はあるかと
ないんですよ だからたまたま輪廻の中で幸福になっても
その瞬間それ分よりは 100倍
200倍  300  3000倍ぐらい
また不幸の輪廻転生をしなくちゃいけない
やっと幸福になっちゃうと
またもうというふうな
輪廻っていうのはとてつもない恐ろしいものであるということを仏教で言うものなんです
ひとかけらのありがたみはないんだと
死んだってもいいや もう生まれ変わるんだからっていうのは
それはそんなに甘い話ではありませんと
だから賢者が脱出するんだと
そういうわけでも 解脱こそ唯一の答えだよと
輪廻の中でこのなんとか手当とかね
なんとかちょっと粘着テープで回ってなんとかすると
これはできません 無理と
それでもどうしても知りたいでしょ
豊かになっても罪を犯さないように
負債を作らないようにどうすればいいかと知りたいでしょ？解脱することなんです
それでも仏教の解脱しない信者さんたちがやることは
やっぱり日々お布施をする
だから仏教徒たちがお布施することにはえらいこってます
だから自分がミャンマー人でもこちらでもね
バイトやらすごい苦しい仕事してるでしょうに
すごく苦しい仕事 レストランからいろんなところ
ものすごく苦しい仕事して
なんとかちょっとお金もらった瞬間で一部をお布施するんだぞというね
いつでも自分もらったお金で一部はお
することにも必ず決めているんですね
それだけ自分の喜びにするんだ
これが楽しみだと このお布施する分が
そうやって楽しみは自分でご飯食べることにはあまりしないんですね
だから自分でごちそうを作って食べて楽しむことよりも
ごちそう作ったらみんな来て来て来て
食べて食べて食べてよと
それでみんなで分けて食べる
そこが楽しんじゃうんですよ
家のお子さんが大変ですけど
いろいろ料理作ったりとかね
あの苦労は全然気にしない
家にあの人来てご飯食べて帰ったぞとかね
そういう風に何かもう日本やら西洋人から見ればすごくバカバカらしい生き方
自分のものは自分だけで食べれば
鍵をかけてね もう 40枚ぐらい
もう 40個ぐらいかけて食べるのは当たり前ではないかと
逆に全部鍵を開けてドアを開けて置くんですよ
それで私は子供の頃すぐ言われたっていうことは
やっぱりドア閉めるなよと
で まあこんな日本みたいにすごいところではなくて
貧しいところなんですけど
床に腰をかけてご飯食べる時でも
その部屋をドア開けておくんです
それ悪いと ドア閉めたっていうことは
誰も入るなよということなんですよ
すごく気をつける で 出家したらそれを厳密に消してドアを閉めて食べてはいけませんと
日本に来たらこれは無理なんですね
ドア開けておくわけにはいきませんし
自動的にドア閉めるし
何か器具つけてますからね
だからドアを開けておくことというのは
国も全部もうオープンですから
もし誰かが旅行に行くのは行ったらすぐ呼んで
今ご飯の時間ですから
どうぞどうぞご飯食べてくださいと
一応こちらでは言う分は言う
相手は食べるか食べないかはこれは相手の条件ですけど
それぐらい自分のご飯でも食べる時は気を付けるということはしていてしていたんです
今の状況はわかりませんですけどね
それがこのアヌノーという言葉の意味なんですね
負債なくという それでアンリマーラ長老がもう悟り開いたんだから
もう煩悩っていうのはひとかけらもないんですよ
ですから ご飯食べても負債はなし
だから負債なきという言葉を使っているのは
阿羅漢になった人にだけ
だから普通の人々はもう我々も誰にも負債作っているわけじゃないって思っても
仏教はあんた阿羅漢悟ってるんですかと聞いている
はい 次に行きま
す パマデマヌヨンジャンティバーラドゥンメーディノージャナアッパマダンジャメーダーヴィーダナングセッタンウェラックティパマデマヌヨンジャンティバーラドゥ
ンメーディノージャナアッパマダンジャメーダーヴィーダナングセッタンウェラックティパマダンアヌンジャンティパマダンっていうのは放逸というかね
怠ることというかね そればっかりアヌンジャンティやっていますよと
バーラドゥンメーディノージャナ
バーラっていうのはちょっとちょっと軽視している言葉なんですね
年下というか もう見下ろしていることなんですけど
無知な人々 ドゥンメーディノージャナというのは智慧は全くない
一般の人のことなんですけどね
智慧のないこういう人々はパマダンアヌンジャンティ放逸ばっかり喜んでいるんだと
いわゆるふざけて生きてるんだよと
みんな食べて遊んで もう噂ばっかり喋ったりして
1 日中それしか仕事をするはそれにしか能がないんですね
だから 1 日中欲貪瞋痴でしか生きてないんですね
忙しい 忙しい 何に忙しいかというともう仕事に行かなくちゃいかんとかね
洗濯しなくちゃいかんとかね
それで人生は終わってしまう
一生仕事をして 洗濯して
料理して 掃除して それで終わりと
それこそ素晴らしい人生やと思ってるんですね
だから結局もう食べて寝るだけの人生なんですよ
だから食べて寝るだけなんですけど
食べてということは寝ることで成り立ちません
だから仕事をするんですね
それで残念なことに仕事をする時はもう食べる暇がなくなるという風にもなっているんですね
そういうことで もう寝る暇もなく仕事をしたりして
もうとにかく食べて仕事をして寝て年取って死ぬというぐらいの人生で
ただふざけているだけのことだと
それは愚かな生き方やと
みんなこのパマダだけ喜んでいるんだと
アッパマーダン 不放逸
この瞬間 ヴィパッサナーのことなんですね
瞬間瞬間自分やってることに気づく
貪瞋痴がない客観的な状態で
今の瞬間で何やってる
今の瞬間で何をやってるか
今の瞬間何をやってるか
今の瞬間の心はどういう状況かと
その瞬間瞬間気づくことは大変な仕事ですよ
放逸でも人に怠け者にできることじゃないんです
だからアッパマーダっていうのは
仏教の仏道そのものなんです
八正道そのものなんです
だから修行そのものなんです
簡単な一言で言えば不放逸
それで不放逸こそ偉大な宝物として賢者が守ると
ダナンセッタンワラッカティ
偉大なる宝物は不放逸なんですよ
財産ではないんです 財産というのは負債作っちゃうんだからね
ご飯でもないんです 服でもないんです
そんなものは全部負債ばっかしになるんです
だから瞬間瞬間気づくサティこそが
修行こそが偉大なる財産ですよ
それは守るんだと 次に
マーパマーデマヌユンジェーテマーカーマラティサンテワンアッパマットヒジャヤントパッポーティプランスカン
マーパマーデマヌユンジェーテ
パマーダというこの もうなんて言いますか
ふさけて汚れて生活すること
放逸で それはマーヌユンジェーテ
やるなかれと やってはいけませんと
マーカーマラティサンテワン
カーマラティっていうのは欲の楽に浸しもなかれと
いわゆる音楽を聴いたり
美しいものを見たり 美味しいものを食べたり
それだけの人生はダメですよと
やるなかれと ご飯食べたっても
無執着の心で食いなさいと
たとえご馳走であろうとも
ああ 美味しいっていうことではなくて
まあそれでなんとか体を維持するんだぞと
食べなきゃ壊れるんだから
なんとか食べますよぐらいの
なんかこのまああまり奢れないようにやってくださいと
それは出家に言ってることですけどね
それでアッパマットヒジャヤント
放逸でちゃんと瞑想する
修行するとパッポーティプランスカン
偉大なる幸福になるんだぞと
サーガタンナアパガタンナイダンデュンマンティタンママパティバッテーすダンメスーヤンセッタンタドゥパガミン
サーガタン よく気入りましたと
まあサーガタンというのは我々はいらっしゃいという言葉でもパーリ語で使います
その場合はサーガタンでもいいし
スワーガタンでもいいんですけどね
まあよく来ましたと まあよくいらっしゃいましたと言っちゃうと逆に逆になりますけど
自分が自分のこと言ってますからね
日本訳とはちょっと変わりますけど
サーガタンというのはよく自分が入ってしまった
至ってしまった ナアパガタン
間違って 違ったわけじゃないと
ということは 涅槃に入りましたと
欲も涅槃を体験しましたということで
いわゆるアパガタンというのは逸れたわけじゃない
道を迷ったわけじゃないということで
アパガタっていうのはゴーアウェイ
ゴーストレートということで
サガタンというのは入ったと正しくね
ヒット 英語で言えばちょっとそこを英語を使わなくちゃいけないので
ヒットポイント ヒットターゲットって言うんですけど
ちゃんと入ったと 迷わなかったと
ナイダン ドゥンマンティタン
自分の考え方がドゥンマンティタンというのは
変なことを考えたっていうこと
ナイダン 私は変なことを考えて変な宗教に入ったわけじゃないんだと
俗的に言えば ドゥンマンティタンというのは
まあまあ間違って考えること
ナイダン 私は変な間違った思考は持っていたわけじゃない
私の考え方は間違ってはなかったと
欲相解脱しましたと 私の考え方は間違ってなかったよと
パティバッテース ダンメーソ ヤンセッタン タドゥ パーガマン
パティバッテの日本訳
日本訳はちょっと分からなくなりましたから
注釈書から説明しますけど
注釈書にもありがたいことに説明していない
パティバッテ ダンメーソ
おそらくパティバッタ
いろいろ法はお釈迦様はいろんな分別してやりますから
その真理であるか法であろうが
分別してやるんですね
あらゆる分別のセットでお釈迦様が説明しているダンマの中で
ヤンセッタン一番上のものはタドゥ パーガマン
それを私は体験しましたと
法と言えば欲も法でしょうし
怒りも法でしょうし 真理だから全部
煩悩も法でしょうしね
だからそれを全部ちゃんと分別してあるんですね
禅定も一つの法でしょうしね
その中でランクつけてますから
お釈迦様が そこで最高なランクにつけてる法
いわゆる涅槃ですね それを私はやりましたと
ウパーガミンというのは至りましたと
サーガタン ナーアパガタン ナイダン ドゥンマンティタン ママ
また同じ意味で 欲相涅槃に入りましたと
考え方は間違っていなかったと
ティッソー ヴィッジャー アヌッパット
三慧を体験しましたと
三つの智慧 三つの智慧っていうのは
自分の過去を見られる智慧と
生命の生死 生まれて死ぬその過程を見られる智慧と
煩悩なくなりましたという智慧なんですね
カタン ブッダッサ サーサナ
ブッダの教えは完成しましたと
ということで終わります
ですから アングリマーラ長老のような
長老っていうのは教祖アングリマーラ教祖のような
あまりもとてつもない恐ろしい人であろうとも
もう救い道がないんですよ
ヴィパッサナーやるしか
それでアングリマーラ長老がすごい悪い人間だと言ったって
我々は何でしょうかね
我々も瞬間瞬間 結局貪瞋痴で生きているんだから
どうした差がないんですよ
大した差は たまたまあの人は人を殺したということだけで
人殺しはすごい悪いと人間が思っているだけのことで
人でも生命でも同じことだからね
我々は生命もいっぱい殺しているでしょうね
一人一人に聞けば あんたどれぐらい生命を殺しているか数えられますかね
アングリマーラ長老の場合は
たまたま数えられただけのことで
そこでおそらく菜食主義でしょ
人殺したっても ですから
まあもしかすると罪が少ないかも
ということもあります
どちらにしたっても 罪を犯しても犯さなくても
人間はやっぱりはめられてます
法則の中で ですから 解脱するしか道がありませんということで
説論でこの経典は終わります
[ページをめくる音]